ABBY CAREY: Hey, I'm Abby.
And this is a look at Cloud
Code support for custom samples.
Enterprise application
development
poses unique challenges when
juggling multiple organization
requirements and dependencies.
But what if you had a
central starting point
to build applications configured
to your organization's needs?
That's where Cloud Code's custom
samples feature can help out.
Custom samples can be starter
applications, services,
or infrastructure
configurations that are
easy to share with your team.
This gives your team a
convenient, secure, and
discoverable starting
point that adheres
to your organization's tech
stack and compliance needs.
Custom samples also
encourage best practices
at the beginning of
your development cycle
and helps accelerate the time
to market for your team's ideas.
To get started with
custom samples,
your organization first
needs to define applications
and services in a
version to Git repo that
includes their techniques for
improving security, compliance,
and other requirements.
Once configured, this is
called a custom samples repo.
Developers with permission
to the custom samples repo
can then use Cloud Code to
connect to your organization's
custom samples repo,
letting them easily import
individual apps and services.
That way, your developers spend
more time coding and less time
configuring apps to meet your
organization's requirements.
Cloud Code is available
for a variety of IDEs,
including Jet Brands IDEs,
VSCode, and Cloud Shell Editor.
For this video, I'll
demo custom samples
with Visual Studio code.
I already have Cloud Code
installed from the VSCode
extensions marketplace.
So I'm ready to go.
Let's say, my
engineering manager
has set up a custom samples
repo of starter applications
that my team frequently uses.
All these apps can easily
be imported into my IDE's
Workspace with Cloud Code.
To show what this
flow looks like,
I'll use an example Git repo
the Cloud Code team made.
What makes this Git repo
a custom samples repo is
the inclusion of one file--
.cctemplate.
They look something like this.
Every samples
folder in your repo
needs to be referenced
in this file.
But let's go back to importing
those custom samples repo.
First, I'll grab the
Git URL for the repo.
Switching back over
to VSCode, I can
go through the same flow
of creating a sample app.
But instead of selecting a
Kubernetes or Cloud Run app,
I'll instead click
Custom Application.
Then, I'll click Import
Sample from repo and paste
in the URL of the repo.
All the samples from
that repo are now
ready to be individually
imported into my Workspace.
And now, I'm ready to
code up a surface that
has all the dependencies
I need already included.
If you want to set
up a custom samples
repo for your
organization, you can
fork our example,
custom samples repo,
and customize it to meet
your organization's needs.
If you have any questions or
feature requests about Cloud
Code, join our Slack channel.
Until next time.